اذا يستعد اكثر من 60 مليون من الناخبين
الاتراك للتوجه الى صناديق الاقتراع صباح
غد الاحد لانتخاب رئيس جرير للبلاد يعبر
بالجمهوريه نحو مئويتها الثانيه اضافه الى
600 نائب يشكلون البرلمان الجديد ومنذ
الساعه السادسه من مساء اليوم بالتوقيت
المحلي دخلت تركيا مرحله الصمت الانتخابي
بشكل رسمي حيث تم حظر الدعايه الانتخابيه
بكل اشكالها يتنافس على منصب الرئاسه
الرئيس التركي الحالي ومرشح تحالف الجمهور
رجب طيب اردوغان الذي يطمح الى الفوز
بولايه ثانيه واخيرا بعد تحول البلاد الى
النظام الرئاسي ومرشح تحالف الشعب وزعيم
حزب الشعب الجمهوري كمال كريشتار اوغلو
ومرشح تحالف الاجداد سنان اوغان وكان مرشح
حزب البلد محرم انجي قد قرر الانسحاب امس
الجمعه من السباق الرئاسي ويتنافس 24 حزبا
سياسي ا على المقاعد 600 الممثله في
البرلمان التركي
[موسيقى]